docteur philippe emmanueli médecins
français exerçant en espagne bonsoir
docteur merci à d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france l'espagne qui a
donc franchi la barre des 18 mille morts
recensés léger rebond par rapport à la
veille mais qui entame tout de même
c'est la bonne nouvelle un processus de
sortie un léger mieux votre regard sur
la stratégie du gouvernement espagnol
beaucoup de morts mais en même temps on
pense aux déconfinement déjà ces risques
est ici chacun retient son souffle
c'est l'opération en quelque sorte
quitte ou double kit si les mesures
barrières qui sont appliqués à
l'occasion de ce retour aux activités
essentielles et non essentiels
fonctionnent double si jamais on assiste
à un rebond à la fois des contaminations
et des morts dans quinze jours c'est
vrai que ce retour au confinement se
fait dans une certaine confusion parce
que les scientifiques ont réaffirmé leur
opposition
mais le gouvernement central n'avait pas
vraiment le choix avec notamment
l'impossibilité d'indemniser tous les
champs bas en temps et en heure parce
que il l'a bien annoncer seuls 3% des
salariés qui avaient été mis au chômage
partiel pourront être indemnisés
effectivement en temps et en heure si on
vous décrypte bien docteur emmanueli
le gouvernement espagnol a fait le choix
de l'économie au détriment peut-être de
la santé et peut-être d'une crise
sanitaire qui va s'amplifier en espagne
selon vous c'est vos craintes se sont
vos craintes
il faut dire que le fmi aujourd'hui
annoncé pour l'espagne une baisse de 8%
du pib dans ses nouvelles prévisions et
estimé que le chômage allait remonter à
20% avec une crise qui nourrit keane qui
n'auraient aucune aucune crise
comparable
lors du siècle dernier depuis 1929 et
c'est vrai qu'on sent bien que les
salariés qui n'ont plus de ressources
depuis un mois pouvait difficilement
peut-être attendre un mois
supplémentaire pour retrouver des
ressources vitales
elles ont néanmoins il ya quand même une
bonne nouvelle en espagne ces sept
livraisons massives de masques cette
distribution notamment pour les
personnes qui sont allés travailler dans
les industries
c'est rassurant quand même oui c'est
vrai que la population découvert ce
matin en prenant le chemin du travail
que effectivement les masques étaient
bien rares à l'entrée des métros et
effectivement c'est vraiment un
soulagement pour la population d'avoir
accès à ces masques sans devoir passer
par des chemins détournés parce que
effectivement le trafic de masse qui
s'ils existent comme partout et
aujourd'hui oui les masques et est
disponible dans les principaux métro de
barcelone et madrid est là quand on
pense déconfinement pense masque mais on
pense aussi évidemment test quid des
tests en espagne est ce que c'est la
même situation qu'en france on a du mal
à tester les gens les tester
efficacement
alors on a toujours beaucoup de mal à
avoir accès aux tests
ils sont annoncés de façon massive pour
la semaine prochaine ils seront
réservées donc en priorité aux
professionnels de santé pour dépister
les professionnels de santé qui sont
éventuellement asymptomatique et
susceptibles de transmettre le virus est
également aux personnes qui sont
symptomatiques c'est-à-dire qu'ils
présentent des signes de l'infection
aujourd'hui ils sont annoncés de façon
massive pour la semaine prochaine
alors vous qui êtes français mais
exercer on l'a dit en espagne
quel regard vous portez sur la gestion
de la crise aussi bien en espagne qu'en
france on le rappelle un l'espagne qui a
payé qui payent un lourd tribut 18 mille
morts écoutez c'est difficile de jeter
un regard particulier sur sur la gestion
de cette crise parce que nous faisons
face à un évènement sans précédent et il
faut rappeler aux téléspectateurs que ce
n'est pas l'émergence non plus de
n'importe quel germe s'agit d'une
zoonose d'ailleurs d'une maladie animale
à transmission humaine et c'est aux
noces font partie des maladies les plus
mal connu ce que ce qui fait aujourd'hui
la difficulté de la gestion de ces
crises parce que on ne sait rien des
conséquences à long terme de ce virus
on ne sait rien aujourd'hui des
traitements potentiellement curatif
on ne sait rien de la probabilité
d'avoir un virus de voir pardon un
vaccin à court terme d'ici un an
alors ça mérite de la clarté de la
franchise mais enfin c'est pas très
rassurant pour pour nous pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous écoutent ça
veut dire aujourd'hui que toutes les
pistes les traitements emmanuel macron
l'a rappelé en tout cas pour la france
on est vraiment au travail vous vous
n'avez pas vraiment d'espoir en ces
traitements on a beaucoup parlé de la
chloroquine notamment en france par
exemple
écoutez moi je crois que deux choses la
première chose c'est que l'accord ans
qui n'a été largement distribués dans
les hôpitaux en espagne ici les patients
nous avons eu cure été hospitalisé en
espagne ont eu d'accord ans keane et le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
chiffres de mortalité en espagne ne
traduisent pas une différence
particulière par rapport aux autres pays
or la chloroquine a été utilisé et puis
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes et en fait on
s'efface en gros à trois scénarios le
premier scénario
c'est une épidémie qui s'épuise réd elle
même peut-être par exemple parce que ce
virus serait sensible à la température
et que l'été permettrait de terminer
cette grande vague de pénétration du
virus du coronavirus deuxième scénario
c'est l'arrivée effectivement d'un
médicament ou d'un vaccin
mais aujourd'hui on n'a absolument
aucune idée du terme dans lequel ça
pourrait effectivement arriver ça c'est
le deuxième scénario à médicament arrive
un vaccin arrive l'épidémie arrête
nice à rennes et puis il ya ce troisième
scénario qu'on ne peut pas exclure
aujourd'hui qui est le fait que la
recherche ne permettent pas de trouver
un médicament à court terme ne
permettent pas de trouver un vaccin à
court terme et que ce qui se dit
aujourd'hui aussi par rapport à ce type
de virus c'est que les anticorps aurait
ignoré de protection relativement limité
on parle sûre en tout cas les autres
coronavirus qu'on connaît déjà d'une
protection des anticorps qui serait de 3
à 4 mois et dans ce scénario on se
retrouverait effectivement dans un
nouveau monde avec des cycles réinfectés
de virus des gens qui s'effectueraient
qu'il serait infecterait et à ce moment
là ça serait un bouleversement total
dans l'organisation des sociétés jusqu'à
l'arrivée d'un traitement ou d'un vaccin
il ce troisième scénario qui est
possible ne peut pas être exclu au jour
d'aujourd'hui
bon eh bien merci docteur philippe
emmanueli médecins français exerçant en
espagne merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france